ما الذي جاء به دون سابق اعلان تمت زياره
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي لعمان ليس معروفا
ماذا سمع منه العاهل الاردني الذي جمعه به
لقاء النادر هو الاول منذ عوده بنيامين
نتنياهو الى السلطه في تل ابيب لكن ما
اسمعه الملك عبد الله الثاني لنتنياهو
ذكره بيان من الديوان الملكي قال البيان
ان العاهره الاردنيه شدد على ضروره احترام
الوضع التاريخي والقانوني القائم في الحرم
القدسي الشريف وعدم المساسبه واكد الملك
عبد الله الثاني ايضا على ضروره الالتزام
بالتهدئه ووقف اعمال العنف لفتح المجال
امام افق سياسي لعمليه السلام كما جدد
الملك والتاكيد على موقف الاردن الثابت
الداع الى الالتزام بحل الدولتين بحيث
يضمن قيام دوله فلسطينيه مستقله
ديوان رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي لا يذكر
شيئا من ذلك وانما يشير الى مناقشه لقاء
عمان ما قال انها القضايا الاقليميه
وتعزيز التعاون الاستراتيجي والامني
والاقتصادي بين اسرائيل والاردن بما يساهم
في استقرار المنطقه تحيدو عن ذلك وسائل
الاعلام الاسرائيليه حين تقول ان نتنياهو
تعاهد خلال لقائه العاهره الاردنيه
بالحفاظ على الوضع التاريخي والقانوني
للاقصى وذاك اقرب مكان
له المفاجاه جوا الى العاصمه الاردنيه في
اسرائيل التي تربطها معاهده سلام مع
المملكه الهاشميه تعترف بوسايتها على
المقدسات الاسلاميه
بمقدم حكومه الاسرائيليه يحتل فيها رموز
اليمين المتطرف مواقع نافذه
وزير الامن القومي المتطرف اثمار بن جرير
كما نذكر فترته الوزاريه باقتحام باحات
الحرم القدسي
وتلاته محاولات تدليس مماثله من قبل
متطرفين يهود شجعتهم على ذلك تركيبه حكومه
لتنياهو الجديده
التوتر في الاراضي الفلسطينيه على وقع
تصعيد الاحتلال تصعيد لا يبدا بالمداهمات
والاعتقالات في الضفه الغربيه ولا ينتهي
عند اشتعاله ازمه اجلاء سكاني تجمع الخان
الاحمر الى الشرق من مدينه القدس
للغايه ولم يتخلف عن ذلك مستشار الامن
القومي الامريكي الذي زار المنطقه تمهيدا
لزياره المقبله لوزير خارجيه بلده
التحذير من تقويض حل الدولتين تصدر اجنده
جاك سوليفان تلك رساله اول وارفعي شخصيه
سياسيه امريكيه تلتقي اقطاب الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الجديده الموصوفه بالاكثر
تصرفا سياسيا ودينيا راس الحكومه بدل
مازوما في الداخل ايضا
وزير الصحه والداخليه اريا درعي بقرار من
المحكمه العليا
تتسع المظاهرات المناوره لسياسه حكومته